I heard that bitching so I got a looks
very dated though the time frame that I
was there and specifically the venue the
Chicago House was the most amazing venue
that's like this opportunity for me now
it's the only place that I would ever
have been not gonna mansion in the
country where I would have been able to
grow like this run on pins and needles
talking or performing in front of you I
did that and I ran the place for three
years and it gave me the ability in the
theater environment I can perform my
songs and she told me that if you
complain you're playing for the world
it's just something about the way the
intimacy of the environment so based on
that I'm biased to say that it's so much
more nurturing in Austin but as hardcore
as this place is I'm amazed as some of
the people that I needed some of the
different opportunities and venues there
was like no this is amazing so it's all
here too it's just you're gonna might
not really know or anything can happen
to you can actually be lily- there's a
lot of negativity here but I think it's
real - you have to come with it or
whatever that but in Austin you don't
have to necessarily do that I used to do
the same three songs for I don't know
how long and then quietly whispered to
me Keaveney has such a wonderful yeah
thank you could you do a few more